c'est la nouvelle république éditions du
loir et cher qui a donné l alerte dans
le département deux mille hectares ont
été semées avec du colza ogm
depuis c'est la loi du silence qui
prévaut du côté d'accès real la
coopérative qui a vendu par erreur ses
semences venus d'argentine
aucune réaction malgré nos
sollicitations et pas davantage du côté
des chambres d'agriculture enfin
impossible d'obtenir des informations de
la part des agriculteurs concernés
et pour cause ils ont signé un protocole
d'indemnisation avec la célébrissime
firme monsanto bailleurs qui les oblige
à se taire bien évidemment ce protocole
d'accord prévoit l'élimination et
semences contaminées par les ogm par la
fauche aux agriculteurs bio en
loir-et-cher lui ne croit pas que ce
danger de contamination sera écartée et
pour deux raisons pour moi c'est
impossible tout soit détruit secret
tellement mosan taux ne le détruit que
les parcelles semées uniquement avec
ceux des le cab exception sauf erreur en
ce qui concerne la variété mais si vous
voulez tout agriculteur enfin moi le
premier je sème toujours plusieurs dans
la même espèce je sème plusieurs vagues
et variétés et en l'occurrence quand
vous passez d'un champ dans l'autre que
vous changez de deux variétés il ya
toujours deux ou trois kilos dans le
square et 2 ou 3 kilos c'est
l'équivalent d'un semis sur un hectare
par ailleurs le colza ogm une fois
sommeil peut échapper à l'arrachage pour
sortir plus tard on peut considérer que
qui au bout de sept ans vous avez
l'équivalent d'une semence ha c'est à
dire deux ou trois kilos qui repousse du
à la dormance
c'est quoi la dormance la dormance et
bien c'est à dire que le colza et quand
il un candidat en terre d'haïti
il attend d'avoir des conditions
pédoclimatiques favorable pour pouvoir
refermer
bernard fau show est le seul agriculteur
avoir accepté de s'exprimer tant la
pression est grande sur le milieu
agricole
un monde agricole concerné par cette
contamination gm dans d'autres
départements de la région dont l'art et
loire et dans la france entière à
hauteur de 8000 hectares